Ajax allows you to exchange data from a
server without reloading the entire page
the jQuery AJAX methods can be used to
request or send text HTML XML or JSON
from a remote server different browsers
have different syntax for Ajax
implementation but jQuery makes it
simple to use Ajax that works with all
browsers with a single line of code now
this is how you use Ajax with vanilla
JavaScript and you can see there's quite
a few lines of code here I'm gonna show
you how to change this all to one line
of code using jQuery before I tell you
that I want to show you this line right
here so we are getting data from another
website and this is the actual website
we're getting the data from HTTP colon
slash slash Karnes at CC slash codes
last aid react example dot txt we have
to add this part because of a cores
error and because of getting data from a
insecure website from a secure website
this is just a course proxy that you can
use in development if you're having
trouble getting data from another
website in a live situation you would
want both websites to be secure and then
you would have to add some specific
headers but this proxy will be good
enough for now to get this data so I'm
going to comment out all of this and
then we're just gonna put one line at
the beginning first we are going to
select what which element we are going
to load the Ajak data into so we're
gonna use the demo element with the ID
demo up there and then dot load so
pretty much all this code is being
replaced with dot load I'm just going to
copy this website address this is the
website we're loading the data from and
that's the whole lines I'm gonna run
this code let's test it out I'm gonna
click change content and it changes
subscribe to the free code camp youtube
channel that those words aren't anywhere
on here that's getting loaded from this
website right here so you can see that
ajax can really help you simplify your
code
with this load method you can also pass
a callback which just means a function
to run as soon as if we get the data
okay I just paste it in this here okay
we're gonna load the text as we did
before but now afterwards we're gonna
run this callback function in the
callback function we have the response
text status text and the xhr
so if the status text equals success
that just means we've successfully
gotten the data and then we can alert
external content loaded successfully if
this dashed x equals err we can alert
what the air was you're always going to
get some kind of response after you you
try to do an ajax call a lot of things
can go wrong with Ajax so you usually
want to set up something that will
happen if there's an error like would
you hear let's see an example of that so
it's going to say external content
loaded successfully and it's going to
load the content now if I change this
website to something that doesn't exist
I'm just going to add a 1 in here and
now let's see what happens when I click
the button err 404 not found so that's
what we're getting this error message
down here okay I'm gonna comment all
this out again and we're gonna add
another line at the top here I'm going
to show you something similar to the
Ajax load command but this is get just
like the load method get' is going to
get data from a server the main
difference is that load is going to load
the data directly into an element and
get is not necessarily going to load
that data into an element here we have
the get method is just dollar sign dot
get and then we're going to pass in what
we're gonna get so the same website from
before and then we have the callback
function this text is not loaded
anywhere so in the callback function
we're going to have to say what's going
to happen to the text in this case we're
just going to console dot log so you can
see in the callback function we have the
data and the status we're showing that
right here the data is going to equal
the data and status is the status
so let's see what happens there but let
me open up the console here you can see
in the bottom corner click change
content and the data is subscribed to
the freako camp YouTube channel status
is success so if you're getting data
that's not text or data that has to be
processed you're gonna want to use the
get method instead of the load method
now the last one I want to tell you
about is the post method so instead of
get you can post now post is a way to
send the data to a server I do not have
my website set up to send data to it so
I'm just going to show you how it works
here so it's gonna be similar where
you're going to have the website that
you're going to access this time you're
going to be sending data to the server
and then you also are gonna have the
callback function but the difference is
you're gonna pass in one more parameter
so here's other parameter the second
parameter is the data that you're trying
to send so this is just some JSON data
and then the callback function is going
to happen after the data is sent so
after you send the data the server can
send back something it could process the
data and send something back or really
it could be anything that could come
back from the server and then you can
run this callback function and you're
going to receive data back from the
server like I said I can't show you an
example because the server isn't set up
to receive data but that's Ajax in
jQuery thanks for watching my name is
beau Carnes don't forget to subscribe
and remember use your code for good